[Musique]
il y a tellement d'argent qui se brosse
dans les gros contrats de transport
public alors c'est quoi au fond quelques
millions de dollars en peau de 20 pour
s'assurer qu'on va décrocher le contrat
c'était sûrement ça le raisonnement à
l'époque chez Alstom on va vous
démontrer comment le géant des
transports s'est servi du Canada dans
son stratagème de corruption
novembre 2019 le quartier des affaires
de Londres bourdonne tout près à l'ombre
des grandes banques une multinationale
française fait face à la justice
l'accusation est grave on lui reproche
d'avoir comploté pour corrompre le
gouvernement de la Tunisie
[Musique]
nous avons obtenu des documents inédits
de cette enquête britannique on y
découvre kalstom a utilisé le Canada
pour camoufler une importante opération
de corruption et de blanchiment d'argent
[Musique]
début des années 2000 c'est la course au
contrat la mondialisation va son plein
et les multinationales veulent leur part
du gâteau
Alstom est un fleuron de l'industrie
française champion de l'énergie et chef
de fil de la fabrication de train
l'entreprise fait d'importantes affaires
un peu partout dans le monde
Brésil Argentine Chine et en Tunisie en
2003 la capitale cherche à moderniser
son système de tramway et lance un appel
d'offre internationale
à l'époque le président Benali dirige
son pays d'une même fête vous savez pas
ce que le lendemain va avoir réserver ni
à vous ni à votre famille
maître Kamel Balti en sait quelque chose
il a quitté la Tunisie pour fuir la
dictature il est aujourd'hui avocat à
Montréal tout le monde avait peur tous
les Tunisiens avaient peur
et la famille de Benali contrôle aussi
de larges pendent l'économie il y a pas
un domaine où ils se sont pas intervenus
pour toucher des commissions tous ces
opérateurs internationaux qui ont des
contrats en Tunisie doivent passer
nécessairement par la famille ou par
Benali lui-même c'est lui qui distribue
ses contrats moyennant restaure
c'est le géant français qui est choisi
pour construire le nouveau tramway le
contrat de 100 millions de dollars et
signé en grande pompe en présence des
premiers ministres des deux pays
pour l'aider dans ces démarches à
l'étranger Alstom fait appel à des
consultants des intermédiaires qui
connaissent les rouages de l'État et qui
facilitent les contacts avec les
décideurs
fais étonnant le consultant pour le
projet de tramway en Tunisie et canadien
Alstom s'engage à lui verser 3% de la
valeur du contrat une somme de plus de 3
millions de dollars la façon de faire
des affaires d'Alstom c'était avec des
intermédiaires cet avocat américain
était directeur juridique de
l'entreprise à l'époque pour la première
fois il se livre à la caméra sur ses
années passées chez Alstom il faut
gagner les contrats faut gagner les
contrats donc ça c'est une message les
gens beaucoup de gens beaucoup
on était convaincus que on soit éliminé
sans les intermédiaires et sans la
corruption
Bender était responsable d'une équipe
internationale de centaines d'avocats
pour Alstom aujourd'hui il se consacre à
l'enseignement à Paris où il a accepté
de nous rencontrer
vous êtes le directeur juridique de
cette société vous allez découvrir
l'ampleur du système comment vous êtes
senti pas très bien
[Musique]
en 2008 la machine à corruption va
commencer à s'enrayer mais on a eu une
descente très importante dans nos
bureaux dans nos
usines si vous oui
de beaucoup de policiers suisses des
perquisitions et donc un drame un vrai
drame
des autorités suisses la compagnie
soupçonnée de gérer une caisse occulte
des consultants d'Alstom ont des noms de
codes et on recourt à des paradis
fiscaux quand quelqu'un un nom de code
c'est pas normal c'est pas normal et
également
quand je vois toujours le Dave bridge
Panama Singapour pour moi les carottes
étaient cuits c'était la corruption en
2011 une filiale suisse est mise à la
menthe pour négligence
l'entreprise se dit même victime de
certains collaborateurs on n'était pas
victimes on était joueur mais la réalité
cette et systématique on était dans une
système
de corruption
globalisée c'est véritablement un
système organisé de corruption à Paris
l'association Sherpa a fait de la
corruption internationale un de ces
sujets de prédilection et est la suivi
le canalstom une corruption
intelligente intégrée au fonctionnement
de l'entreprise et non pas finalement
des actes isolés de brebis galeuses
l'enquête en Suisse va générer une mine
d'informations sur d'autres filiales
d'Alstom dont une à rugby en Angleterre
pas d'employés pas de bureau pas de
compte en banque cette filiale
n'existait que sur papier le Sirius
trade office les Squad anticorruption
britanniques déclenche une enquête dans
Samir le projet de tramway Tunis et le
consultant canadien d'Alstom à Montréal
c'était des pour payer des intimides
c'est pour protéger la maison mais c'est
une partie une réussite
[Musique]
en 2011 le printemps arabe provoque la
chute du régime en Tunisie le dictateur
Benali fuit en Arabie Saoudite son
beau-frère Bella scène très bellecy se
réfugie à Montréal
[Musique]
très belle scie un riche homme
d'affaires à la tête d'un empire et un
joueur central dans les peaux de vin
versés par Alstom pour le projet de
tramway c'était le parent le parent du
clan Trabelsi par conséquent le parent
du joueur économique en Tunisie donc il
synchronisait tout et puis il domine
d'où vient la fortune du clan Benali
Trabelsi les commissions
très belle scie atterri en jet privé à
l'aéroport montréaltrudo le consultant
canadien d'Alstom est là pour
l'accueillir le beau-frère milliardaire
du président celui qu'on appelait là-bas
le parrain et ça dit tout
bonjour la nouvelle de son arrivée au
pays se propage rapidement y a-t-il la
colère
c'est une enfant c'est une insulte un
intelligence du peuple québécois
canadien que de recevoir un corrompu
très belle scie demande le statut de
réfugiés le gouvernement canadien s'y
oppose le gouvernement ne veut pas
accepter l'ancien président de la
Tunisie et ceux ou celles qui sont
membres de sanguin
sera entendue par la commission
d'immigration à huis clos
sur ces images captées par une équipe
française on voit Bella scène très belle
scie à Montréal il se fait discret et
refuse les entrevues on jouant
une expertise des activités financières
de trail si et demandez par le Canada un
dossier volumineux des milliers de pages
qui révèlent un vaste réseau financier
une piste attire surtout l'attention
celle d'Alstom et de son consultant
canadien mais c'était pas un parti
gagner d'avance c'est que c'était
multinationales qui existent depuis des
dizaines d'années et qui ont tout le
temps fait des projets d'envergure
celui qui analysé le dossier de Trabelsi
pour la Commission de l'immigration il
était clair que Einstein était engagé de
façon on va dire systématique dans
certains activités de corruption pour
obtenir des contrats une activité de
corruption elle va pas être seule elle
est souvent accompagnée donc de
blanchiment et d'évasion fiscale je
viens de recevoir un appel de Monsieur T
de Tunisie
les enquêteurs ont découvert dans le
téléphone de Trabelsi saisi au Canada
les coordonnées de plusieurs aux
dirigeants d'Alstom
il a demandé de vous parler il se plaint
qu'il n'a pas encore reçu un seul
paiement tel que promis
très belle super finalement sa cause il
n'obtiendra pas le statut de réfugiés la
preuve était faite que effectivement
tous les transferts de fonds les
entreprises utilisées les individus
impliqués tendez à conclure que il y
avait clairement une une opération une
activité donc de corruption d'agents
publics
très belle scie doit être déporté en
Tunisie mais il s'enfuit du pays le
consultant canadien d'Alstom lui a
toujours pignon sur rue à Montréal
[Musique]
après la pause on vous révèle par où
passer les millions de dollars de pots
de vin d'Alstom à Montréal
[Musique]
le consultant canadien d'Alstom qui
était un roi déterminant dans cette
affaire de corruption n'a jamais été
traduit devant la justice alors imaginez
sa surprise quand notre équipe leur
tracé
[Musique]
nous sommes dans un quartier résidentiel
loin du centre-ville de Montréal
[Musique]
on y découvre une petite maison en ruine
les lieux sont abandonnés il s'agit du
siège social de construction et gestion
néfo la compagnie du consultant canadien
embauché par Alstom
c'est ici que transitait les millions de
dollars d'Alstom destinés à la dictature
tunisienne
le propriétaire de Nesco c'est Elias
nous gêne ingénieur de profession on le
voit ici diplômé de Polytechnique en
1973 la preuve présentée devant la
commission d'immigration révèle des
liens étonnants entre Trabelsi et le
consultant canadien d'Alstom mais quand
on fait en quête on vérifie puis on se
rend compte que nefco n'a jamais fait de
travail en tant que tel
pour un reportage de l'émission Enquête
Elias nous gêne à vous connaître le
beau-frère du dictateur
avec lui simplement
mais il ne s'agissait pas d'une simple
relation d'affaires la GRC mettra la
main sur un document clé une entente
secrète le consultant canadien servait
de prête non pour une obscure société au
Liban rock finance contrôlé par nul
autre que Bella scène Trabelsi un
contrat de prévenant est fait pour
assurer l'anonymat c'est un stratagème
on va dire cliché au standard plus vous
multipliez la présence d'autres entités
dans d'autres juridiction plus ça
complique le travail d'application de la
loi ou de la surveillance ou de la
conformité s'il y a des démarches
légales à faire ça complexifie le
dossier
aucun transfert ne passait par moi rien
ne passait par mois il y a snié tout
transfert de fond à Trabelsi pourtant
dans ce fax il demande à sa banque
d'envoyer 1,3 millions d'euros à
c'est trop facile d'utiliser un prénom
pour créer des entreprises dans les bus
ont-ils ça ne devrait pas être permis
au Canada les ententes de prévenants
sont légales l'ONG transparent si
international mène une campagne pour
alerter l'opinion publique sur les
effets néfastes de la corruption
on a constaté que le Canada en fait
était
vendu à l'étranger comme une destination
justement pour créer des entreprises
comme ça qui servent à cacher l'argent
sale pourquoi tu disais le Canada parce
que le Canada n'attire pas la tension en
fait c'est sûr que vous avez toujours
choisir des endroits où certaines
activités sont reconnues sont légales
sont pas difficiles comme le traitement
comme l'incorporation qui est quand même
facilité le système financier stable et
donc on est victime un petit peu de
notre succès de stabilité
au total Elias nous gêne à transférer
plus de 3 millions de dollars en peau de
vin d'Alstom à Traversy mais aussi des
millions de plusieurs multinationales
dont les noms n'ont jamais été rendus
publics
un prêt de nom
c'est par un obstacle c'est un challenge
c'est pas parce que quelqu'un a un
prénom que on va pas être capable de le
retrouver
avec l'agent de liaison de d'un coin de
l'Afrique on a besoin de une équipe de
la GRC se spécialise dans la lutte
contre la corruption internationale ça
nous occuper de prendre pour les trois
prochains mois nous en question de
longue haleine mais c'est la nature du
crime ce sont les crimes historiques un
crime historique pourrait être capable
de le réseau ça prend plus de travail
parce que la preuve n'est pas à portée
de main
la GRC a frappé un grand coup grâce à
son enquête sur SNC-Lavalin en 2019
l'entreprise appelée des coupables pour
avoir versé des pots de vin en Libye
pourtant le bilan du Canada est critiqué
en 23 ans seulement une personne et
quatre entreprises ont été condamnées
pour corruption internationale c'est
trop peu ce serait surprenant qu'il y
ait pas plus de cas on n'a pas les
statistiques on ne sait pas quelles
enquêtes sont ouvertes qu'est-ce qui se
passe un qui manque de transparence à ce
niveau-là
au tournant de l'an 2000 de nombreux
pays dans la France et le Canada
adoptent des lois pour criminaliser la
corruption de dirigeants étrangers à
l'initiative de le CDA on a signé la
convention de l'OCDE en 1998
je veux dire il est temps qu'on voit des
résultats
à la demande de l'Angleterre la GRC a
effectué des perquisitions Canada dans
le dossier d'Alstom mais l'équipe de
lutte contre la corruption
internationale affirme avoir jamais mené
d'enquête sur Ilias nous aime il n'a
d'ailleurs jamais fait l'objet
d'accusation il y a pas de prescription
donc si le crime est arrivé il y a 15
ans la personne peut être accusée demain
matin il y a pas de limite
[Musique]
le département de la Justice américain
enquêtait aussi sur le stratagème de
corruption de la compagnie en 2014
Alstom accepte de payer un milliard de
dollars une amende record
[Applaudissements]
en France ni Alstom ni aucun de ses
dirigeants n'ont été accusés pour
corruption internationale le risque
français était
très très bas
on est un championnat national on va pas
attaquer Alstom
Frédéric Bender a tenté de faire la
lumière à l'interne sur les pratiques de
corruption d'Alstom j'ai commencé à
faire des enquêtes et je t'ai bloqué et
ça il faut le dire je débloqué donc
comme un accord il quitte la direction
des services juridiques de l'entreprise
en 2011
nous avons demandé une entrevue Alstom
la compagnie a accepté avant de revenir
sur sa décision elle nous a fait
parvenir cette déclaration
Alstom possède un programme d'éthique et
de conformité robuste pour prévenir et
détecter la corruption qui fut l'objet
dans le passé d'un examen externe
approfondi ces revues ont été une
expérience transformatrice
Alstom est aujourd'hui bien implanté au
Canada la compagnie est devenue le
numéro de mondial de l'industrie
ferroviaire grâce à l'acquisition
récente de bombardiers de transport
à l'issue du procès en Angleterre Alstom
a écopé en 2019 d'une amende de 25
millions de dollars pour son stratagème
en Tunisie le consultant canadien Ilias
nous gêne y est clairement identifié
comme un rouage central
nous avons réussi à le retracer
dans cet immeuble à condo
oui bonjour monsieur j'aimerais beaucoup
vous parler parce qu'on prépare un
reportage sur la compagnie Alstom
nous j'aime n'a jamais donné suite à
notre demande d'entrevue
l'ancien siège social deeko sera bientôt
détruit pour faire place à un
développement immobilier
très belle scie a été arrêtée dans une
villa de la Côte d'Azur où il se cachait
sous une fausse identité
malgré la demande de la Tunisie la
justice française refuse de l'extrader
les pots de vin d'Alstom eux n'ont
jamais été retrouvés je pense qu'il faut
qu'on donne le temps au Canada par
rapport à la lutte contre la corruption
à l'étranger et je pense pas qu'on ait
réussi à faire ça jusqu'à maintenant
tout l'argent qui passe dans la
corruption c'est de l'argent qui ne va
pas faire les services publics
essentiels c'est un moyen d'alimenter le
les inégalités et l'injustice dans le
monde appauvrir tout un peuple c'est
plus qu'un crime
si aujourd'hui on se trouve appauvri
c'est vrai à cause des dirigeants mais
également à cause de ses compagnies
internationales les rapaces des finances
et des affaires
[Musique]